how can we quickly find the square of
any two digit number
let's see 31 squared on the left side we
will write three squared and make two
lines
in the middle it will be two multiplied
by the digits here the digits are three
and one
therefore it will be 2 multiplied by 3
multiplied by 1
and the second digit is 1 so in the end
we'll write 1 squared so 3 squared is 9
2 times 3 times 1 is 6 and 1 squared is
1. yours are answered now what will be
the answer of 37 squared on the left
side we will write 3 squared in the
middle we will write 2 times 3 times 7
on the right side we will write the
square of the last digit that is 7
squared
3 squared is 9 the value of this is 42
and 7 squared is 49 by solving it
further we get the answer as 1369.
now using this trick can you find the
value of 73 squared and tell us in the
comments section below for more such
interesting matrix do subscribe to our
youtube channel